[Music]
our series a more perfect union aims to
show that what unites us as Americans is
far greater than what divides us on a
difficult news day here in Washington we
bring you some good news from our
nation's capital one man's dream led him
to quit his government contractor job
and grows some real roots in the
community chip Reid is just a few
rooftops away from us with that story hi
chip
well good morning as you can see I am
right in the heart of Washington DC the
US Capitol behind me in the building I'm
standing on houses a major law firm it's
the last place you'd expect to find a
flourishing garden full of flowers herbs
and vegetables it's all part of rooftop
roots an organization that provides jobs
and food to the people who need them the
most hidden away on the roof of this
fire station and affordable housing
complex is a small garden with big
dreams it's a big sense of
accomplishment
Thomas Snyder built this garden outside
Washington DC back in 2013 an idea that
came to him on a friend's roof deck
we're looking down at this office
building and there's probably 10,000
square feet of just empty roof space Wow
I'll be cool if we could grow food on
that space Snyder was working as a
contractor with the Environmental
Protection Agency but he wanted to do
something with more of a direct
environmental impact so about six months
ago the 36 year old quit his EPA
position to focus on his company rooftop
roots full-time roof space does provide
its own challenges to grow food but it's
better than just a blank space that has
basically nothing going for rooftop
roots has now installed commercial and
residential gardens throughout the DC
area using the profits made from those
gardens to create community gardens in
low-income areas at no cost only 7% of
adults who live at or below the poverty
level eat the daily recommended amount
of vegetables a statistic Schneider
wants to change we're aiming to create
more locally grown food teach
individuals how to grow food create
healthy and nutritious
using the produce from the gardens but
he's not just feeding these communities
he's providing jobs for them too it just
gave me something better to do
Mike Burris used to be homeless on the
streets of DC now he installs gardens
for rooftop roots it gave me a better
outlook on community service and working
in the gardens and an environment
rebuilding the soil and all my life 1 2
dickerson or aunt peaches as she's known
around here is the head gardener atop
this firehouse you don't mind getting
dirty that's why they made water ant
peaches not only hands out the free
fresh produce to her neighbors she also
makes homemade relish out of them what's
the secret to making this the idea of
community gardens to improve quality of
life has taken off in other urban areas
like this community garden in Providence
Rhode Island this rooftop garden on top
of affordable housing in New York City
and this one in Los Angeles Snyder now
has seven community gardens across the
DC region what is the single best thing
about all of this bringing people
together by far if we can really provide
over the long term help break that cycle
of poverty that'll be a dream come true
for me for peaches the single best thing
is the taste of fresh food you can tell
the difference between this and one you
buy the groceries
oh yes mm-hmm delicious absolutely
delicious
makes me hungry the the vegetables that
are grown in this garden are used in the
law firms cafeteria and rooftop roots as
plans big plans to have Gardens like
this on rooftops all over the Washington
DC area and by the way John as you said
I'm only a few blocks away from you why
don't you guys come over after the show
I'll make breakfast promise yeah we'd
love that I'm glad you got to meet our
peaches Dickerson no no relationships
budgets
on a day that is so tense where there's
so much on the line we really needed a
story about people coming together i
peaches and the people like that that's
right and chip always brings it